♪ ♪
>> THESE ARE BAGS, BAGS BEING
THROWN AWAY.
BECAUSE THE MIGRANTS DON'T NEED
HIM.
IN THE DISCO WASTE.
THIS IS ALL FOOD.
IT'S GOING TO WASTE IT'S INSANE.
THIS IS FIRST COME THIS GOOD
FOOD.
GOOD FOOD BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
EAT IT THIS EVENT WILL LIKE IT.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU JUST SAW
IS THIS HUGE AMOUNT OF FOOD THAT
IS BEEN THROWN AWAY DAILY THIS
BIG NEW YORK CITY HOTEL THAT'S
BEEN USED TO HOUSE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, ACCORDING TO THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER MORE THAN 36,400
HAVE COME IN NEW YORK CITY IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS AND CITY
OFFICIALS AND PUT THEM UP IN AT
LEAST 14 HOTELS MORE THAN BEING
THE ROW IN TIMES SQUARE.
NOW THAT'S FOR THE PICTURES THEY
ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW WERE TAKEN.
MY NEXT GUEST FULLY BEAR
RODRIGUEZ'S THAT HE HAS WORKED
THERE SINCE 2017, BUT NOW THE
LEGALS OF TAKEN OVER THE PLACE
IS COMPLETE CHAOS AND FULLY PAY
JOINTS WE NOW, GOOD SEATS AND I
NOW, WHEN YOU SAY CHAOS TELL US
WHAT YOU MEAN, FIGHTS?
DRUGS?
ALTERCATIONS?
OTHER VIOLATIONS?
>> GOOD EVENING LES WOULD HAVE
ME THANK YOU.
THE CHAOS THAT WE SEE TODAY IS
COMPILED BY MIGRANTS BEING
DRUNK, TRICKY ALL DAY SMOKING
MARIJUANA.
PURSUING DRUGS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PEOPLE HAVING
IN THE STAIRS YOUNG PEOPLE,
TEENAGERS.
HE WAS THE FIRE EXIT STAIRS TO
GO IN THERE AND DO WHAT
TEENAGERS DO.
WE HAVE PEOPLE ACTUALLY TRYING
TO ACT LIKE THE HOTEL IS THEIRS
WE HAVE NO RIGHTS.
THE FORM IN WHICH THEY KEEP
THEIR ROOMS IS HORRENDOUS.
NO CLAIMANT NO FOLDER CLOSE.
IT'S IN PILES, PILES, THE
HOLDING CLOSE FROM THE HOLDING
WHAT THEY CAN HOARD.
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
MANY GO TO THE ROOMS AND YOU SAY
SOMETHING.
THE HOTEL MANAGEMENT ESPECIALLY
THE GM THE DIRECTORS WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO TELL THEM NOTHING.
AND PRACTICALLY HAVE
CARTE BLANCHE.
>> SO WHAT YOU WOULD SAY IS YOU
DON'T SEE THIS EXPECTED
GRATITUDE FOR FREE HOUSING, FREE
FOOD OF THE SHELTER IN A CITY OR
RENT IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
NOT SEEING A LOT OF THAT.
>> THERE IS A TIME IN 2017 OR
PAID A LOT OF MONEY TO HOUSE MY
AND MY KIDS PAID THE CABLE
APPEARED TO GOSSIPY THE
LIGHTING.
I DID THE CAR PAYMENTS.
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF THAT ARE
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR.
FORCEFULLY FOR THE MIGRANTS THEY
GOT THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO HAND THEM
CARTE BLANCHE THE PRETTY MUCH DO
AS THEY WISH.
THEY GO IN AND OUT OF THE HOTEL
FOR PEOPLE SICK IN THERE,
SPREADING DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ILLNESSES, CHICKEN POX, COVID.
NOBODY IS SAYING THEY CAN'T DO
THAT.
SO RIGHT NOW THE ONES THAT HAVE
ALL THE POWER OF THE MIGRANTS.
THE HOTEL WORKERS THEY LOST
THEIR POWER AT THE HOTEL.
THE GM DOESN'T HAVE THEIR BACK.
I INITIALLY CARES ABOUT IS
MAKING THE MONEY THAT IS MAKING.
>> Laura: I DON'T MAKE THIS
ABOUT A PERSONAL GRIEVANCE, WERE
INTERESTED IN FELIPE IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE USE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
NEW YORK IS ESTIMATED HAS BEEN
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS, THUS
THE ESTIMATE ON THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN NEW YORK CITY
INCLUDING THE HOUSING THEY ARE
SEEING COMMON OUTWARD SHOWING
PICTURES OF WEED, MARIJUANA THAT
YOU SAID WAS FOUND OF THE
HOTEL'S OUT IF YOU FIND A
QUESTION MARK SO YOU DIDN'T FIND
IT YOU KNOW WHO THIS WHO THIS
BELONG TO?
>> I COLLECTED IT THE MARIJUANA
IT WAS A FIGHT IN THE LOBBY I
WAS THERE THAT NIGHT, OR THE
MIGRANTS WAS DRUNK AND HE TOOK A
SWING AT AN OFFICER AND HIT HIM
ON THE HEAD.
THE SECURITY FOR THE HOTEL TO
COME DOWN AND WHEN HE RESPONDED
NYPD AND TO THE HOTEL IS ABLE
TEENAGERS BY THE STAIRS IN THE
LOBBY GOING TO THE TOP LOBBY
WITH TWO CUPS THE DESTRUCTIVE
WEED ON THE STAIRS AND I'VE SEEN
IT.
I TOOK PICTURES OF IT AND I
COLLECTED IT.
>> Laura: WILL FULLY PAY IF
ALL AMERICANS COULD SEE WHAT
YOU'VE WITNESSED JUST IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS AT THIS HOTEL IN
ONE SENSE WOULD YOU THINK THEY'D
SAY?
>> IT'S A DISGRACE.
>> Laura: YOU'VE DONE MORE TO
ELIMINATE THE SITUATION AND
FRANKLY A LOT OF FOLKS THE MEDIA
BECAUSE HE WOULD INSIDE ACCESS I
WOULD APPRECIA